gençler Merhaba bugünkü dersimizde ısı
sıcaklık ünitesinde çok önemli iki
kavramı öğreneceğiz öz ısı ve Isı sahası
kavramlarını öğreneceğiz bu kavramların
günlük hayatımızda da büyük yeri var
bazı soruların cevapları bunlarda
Örneğin çay demlerken alta su
koyduğunuzda çok doldurursanız neden
daha geç kaynıyor az doldurursanız neden
çabuk kaynıyor kalorifer peteklerinde
neden su kullanıyoruz neden tatil
beldelerinde asıl denize kışın girmen
lazım Burada Deniz çok sıcak oluyor
denir bunların hepsinin cevabı bu iki
kavramda Hemen başlayalım ilk
öğreneceğimiz kavram öz ısı kavramı ya
da diğer ismiyle Özgür ısı kavramı
tanımlar çok önemli buradaki tanım şu;
bir maddeniz var Bu maddenin bir
gramının sıcaklığını bir selsiyus
değiştirmek için o maddeye vermen
gereken ya da o maddeden alman gereken
ısı miktarıdır yani Bir maddeyi ısıtmak
istiyorsan sıcaklığını arttırmak
istiyorsan onu Isı enerjisi vermen lazım
soğutmak istiyorsan da o maddeden Isı
enerjisi alman gerekiyor İşte buradaki
sınırlamalar o madde 1 gram olacak ve
sıcaklık değişimin bir selsiyesi olacak
işte oradaki verilen ya da alınan ısı
miktarına Öz ısıtıyoruz şöyle
bir su bardağı su aynı Öz ısıya sahip
Çünkü ikisi de su madde miktarından
bağımsız burada bir tablo görüyoruz Bu
tablo tam olarak maddelerin öz ısı
değerlerini veriyor Örneğin Gümüş 0.06
kalori bölü gramselcius Öz ısıya
sahipmiş bu ne anlama gelir ki Birimden
de çıkartabilirsiniz birimimiz kalori
bölü gram celcius maddemiz 1 gram
sıcaklığını 1 selsiyus değiştireceğiz ve
zaten payda kısmı 1 oldu geriye ne kaldı
enerji kısmı kaldı yani öz ısı kısmı
kaldı Gümüş için bu verilmesi gereken
enerji miktarı 0.06 kaloriymiş bakırda
bu 0.09 tahtada 0,42 suda bir yani
gördüğünüz gibi aşağıya doğru indikçe öz
ısı miktarı artıyor Yani bütün Bu
maddelerden 1 gram alsak sıcaklıklarını
bir sel suya üstü değiştirmek istersek
suya bir kalori enerji vermem gerekiyor
gümüşe 0.06 vermem gerekiyor Bu
yanındaki değerler de farklı bir birim
olan juli bölü kilogram celsius
cinsinden değerler Tabii ki ezbere
bilmemize gerek yok Bu da beni şu sonuca
götürüyor öz ısı Aslında sıcaklığın ne
kadar hızlı değiştiğinin bir
göstergesidir öz ısısı yüksek olursa
sıcaklık değişimi daha yavaş oluyor
çünkü daha fazla enerji istiyor mesela
suyun öz ısısı gümüşten çok daha fazla
suyu 1 derece ısıtmak için gümüşe göre
çok daha fazla enerji vermen lazım Bu da
daha fazla vakit demek Eğer ocaklarınız
aynı çalışıyorsa sıcaklık değişimi daha
yavaş düşüklerde ise bu sıcaklık
değişimi daha hızlı gerçekleşiyor bakır
hemen ısınır Çünkü öz ısısı çok küçük
ama tahta daha geç ısınır Çünkü öz ısısı
bakıra göre daha fazla aynı şey soğuma
içinde geçerli öz ısısı büyük maddeler
ısıtmakta zordur soğutmak da zordur
dersin başında konuştuğumuz şeye gelelim
neden kalorifer peteklerinde su
kullanılıyor o sistemi biliyorsunuzdur
kombi suyu ısıtıyor içerisinde sıcak
suyu basıyor tesisattan peteklere doğru
kalorifer peteklerine doğru sıcak su
geliyor onun içerisinde sıcak su
dolaşıyor sizin Odanızı o sıcak su
ısıtıyor Peki niye su başka bir sıvı
değil çünkü su öz ısısı en büyük
maddelerden bir tanesi Evet bunu ısıtmak
zor doğru kombinin problemi o ama
ısıttıktan sonra kalorifer peteklerinde
soğumaya başladığında soğuması da zor
Ben zaten mümkün olduğu kadar soğumasın
isterim odayı daha sıcak tutsun isterim
O yüzden kullanılır neden denizler
karalardan daha geç ısınıyor daha geç
soğuyor Çünkü suyun öz ısısı 4187 jul
kilogram/sus şunlar kilojulil olacak
Aynı bu tabloda gördüğümüz şu sağ
sütundaki değerler Kara İse kum olarak
düşünülebilir içerisinde %20 oranında su
olduğu düşünülür bu kumun öz ısısı
yaklaşık bir buçuk yani denizin öz ısısı
çok fazla Karanın öz ısısı daha az öz
ısısı büyükse seni ısıtmak da zor
soğutmak da zor O yüzden denizler daha
geç ısınır daha geç soğur O yüzden tatil
beldelerinde yaşlılar asıl burada denize
kışın gireceksin der Hatta buna aylarla
sınırlandırmayalım bir gün için
düşünelim coğrafya derslerinde
görüyorsunuzdur Gündüz vakti genelde
sıcaklık farkı varsa yaz aylarında
özellikle denizden karaya doğru bir
rüzgar esintisi olur gece vakti ise
Karadan denize doğru bir rüzgar esintisi
olur sebep Çünkü gün içerisinde
özellikle dediğim gibi yaz aylarında
Karalar hemen ısınıyorlar burası sıcak
deniz o kadar iyi ısınamıyor nispeten
soğuk kalıyor Burası soğuk sıcak olan o
Karanın üstündeki hava ısınıyor ısınan
havanın hacmi büyüyor öz kütlesi
küçülüyor Dolayısıyla yukarılara doğru
çıkıyor burada ise tam tersi deniz
seviyesi soğuk soğuyan hava aşağıda
kalır buradaki hava aşağıya iniyor
buradaki hava yükseldiği için Alçak
basınç oluşuyor Burada hava alçı aldığı
için yüksek basınç oluşuyor ve rüzgarlar
yüksek basınçtan alçak basınca doğru
hareket ediyor Yani denizden karaya bir
Esinti gece ise bunun tam tersi oluyor
Gece güneş yok Hava soğudu Kara hemen
soğuyor Bu sefer de deniz Gündüz zaten
geç ısınmıştı tam ısındı Güneş Battı
soğuyamıyor Bu adam gece sıcak kalıyor
Deniz sıcak kalmış oluyor böyle Böylece
sıcağın olduğu ortamda hava yükseliyor
burada Alçak basınç oluşuyor soğuğun
olduğu ortamda Hava alçalıyor burada
yüksek basınç oluşuyor Rüzgar yine
yüksek basınçtan alçak basınca doğru
yani Karadan denize doğru esiyor biraz
da coğrafya dedikten sonra bununla
ilgili bir deneyelim şimdi bu
deneyimizde Öz ısının ne olduğunu daha
net göreceğiz öz ısı büyük olan maddeyi
ısıtmak da zordu soğutmak da zordu küçük
olanı da ısıtmak kolay soğutmakta kolay
burada kaplarımız var kapların
içerisinde aynı miktarda su var bu
suların sıcaklıkları ekranda da
gördüğünüz gibi İkisinde de 20.9 celsius
şurada bir ısıtıcımız var o ısıtıcının
içerisin öz ısıları hakkında yorum
yapmak istediğimiz maddeleri koyacağız
ve onları ısıtacağız aynı sıcaklığa
gelmelerini bekleyeceğiz bu maddelerimiz
bakır ve Can parçaları Yani biz Aslında
Bakırın ve camın Öz ısılarını kıyaslamak
istiyoruz birinci tüpümüze bakır
parçalarını koyuyor bu bakır parçalarını
ısıtacağımız suyun içerisine koyup o
Bakırın sıcaklığını arttırmaya çalışacak
ikinci kabımıza cam parçalarını koyuyor
aynı miktarda Bunlar bunu da aynı
şekilde aynı suya koyup onu da bakırla
beraber ısıtacak yeterince o suyun
içerisine kalacakları için beraber
ısınacakları için su kaynıyorsa Örneğin
ikisinin de 100 selsiyus sıcaklıkta
olduğunu düşünebiliriz hem Bakırın hem
cam yeteri kadar beklediğimizde biz
deneyi yapana kadar sıcaklıklar 19,6'ya
düştü şu kapların içerisindeki
sıcaklıklardan bahsediyorum yoksa bizim
buradaki malzemelerimiz kaynayan suyun
içerisindeler 100 Derece olarak
düşünebiliriz bakın yaklaşık 100
selsiyustaki bakırı aldım buradaki 19 20
celsius'taki suyun içerisine döküyorum
Dolayısıyla sıcak olan soğuyacak soğuk
olan ısınacak benim 100 selsiyustaki
bakarım soğumaya başlayacak bir dengeye
gelecekler nerede dengeye gelecekler
buradaki ekranda
hangisi kavramıyla ilişkilendirilebilir
diye sorulmuş kalorifer peteklerinde su
kullanılması zaten bunu az önce konuştuk
suyun öz ısısı birçok maddeden daha
büyüktür birçok madde sıfır virgüllü bir
sayıyı iken kalori cinsinden konuşuyorum
Çünkü birdir bu suyu ısıttıktan sonra
soğuması zor olduğu için kullanıyoruz
Çünkü odamız hemen soğusun istemiyoruz
Ada iklimlerinin ılıman olması
Ada dediğin şey bir tane kara parçası
nerede denizin ortasında bunun etrafı
Dört tarafı denizlerle çevrili Ortamda
çok su var yani Ortamda çok su varsa o
su senin iklimini değiştirir oradaki
iklim Yani bu Adadaki iklim ılıman olur
Ne çok sıcak olur Ne çok soğuk olur İç
Anadolu yaşayanlarınız bilir Konya'da
Kayseri'de ya da Ankara'da karasal iklim
vardır Bu ne demek öyle sıcağında 30
celsius olan hava sıcaklığı gece 15'e
düşebilir üşüyebilirsiniz yorganla
yatabilirsiniz gündüz kavrulurken bu
Çöllerde daha da belirgindir Çöller
Karasal iklimin dibidir Çünkü ortamda
Deniz namına hiçbir şey yoktur gündüz
çok sıcaktır gece çok soğuktur ama bir
yerde Deniz varsa Göl varsa bir su
birikintisi varsa senin iklimini
etkileyebilecek miktarda su varsa
ılıman olursun uçlarda yaşamazsın belli
Aralık sıcak çay dökülen porselen
fincanın hemen ısınırken sıcak çayın çok
fazla soğumaması şimdi porselenimiz
soğuk dolaptan aldık içine yükseltiyorsa
çay koyuyoruz porselene el değmiyor
Hemen yüz selci ise çıkabiliyor hemen
sıcaklığı çok artıyor çay ise çok
soğumuyor buz gibi olmuyor anında neden
bu ikisi bir araya geldiklerinde Isı
alışverişi yapıyorlar sıcak olan çay Isı
enerjisi veriyor porselen ısıtıyor çay
enerji verdiği için soğumaya başlıyor
porselen de enerji aldığı için ısınmaya
başlıyor soğuma kötü ısınma çok iyi
çünkü porselenin öz ısısı çayın Yani
aslında suyun öz ısısından Küçükte ondan
Öz ısın küçükse hemen ısınır hemen
soğursun kolay ısınırsın kolaysa Öz ısın
büyükse bu zordur Dolayısıyla bire ikiye
ve üçe öz ısı kavramıyla ilişkilidir
diyebiliriz şimdi bir başka soru
dersimize yön versin diyor ki; aynı
ısıtıcı bir bardak su ile bir çaydanlık
suyu aynı sürede mi kaynatır yine dersin
başında konuştuğumuz sorularımızdan
Hocam şu ana kadar anlattığınızdan
anladığıma göre ısınmayı soğumayı
belirleyen şey öz ısı şimdi ikisi de su
çay boyutta da su var bardakta da su var
Dolayısıyla bunlar aynı kolaylıkla
ısınır aynı kolaylıkla soğurlar Eğer
ikisinden de bir gram aldıysan Evet
çünkü Öz ısısının tanımı çok önemli Bir
gramın sıcaklığını bir selsius
değiştirmek için verilmesi ya da
alınması gereken enerji bu miktarlar
farklı olursa artık orada konuştuğun
kavram öz ısı olmaz Öz ısıyla ilişkili
başka bir kavram olur yani
ısı sığası kavramı Olur diğer ismiyle
ısı kapasitesi kavramı olur Öz ısıya çok
benzer Çünkü içerisinde öz ısı vardır
fakat
Isı sahası dediğimiz şey madde miktarı
ile öz ısının beraber düşünülmesidir
yani kütle ile öz ısısı beraber
düşünüldüğünde ortaya çıkan kavraması
sahası yine tanım çok önemli diyor ki;
Bir maddenin sıcaklığını bir selsiyus
değiştirmek için madde verilmesi ya da
maddeden alınması gereken nasıl miktarı
Hocam özdası işte bu Hayır Özbekistan'a
vardı Bir gram sınırlandırması vardı
burada Gramın bir önemi yok Herhangi
miktarda bir madde Şimdi size soru bir
bardak suyunuz var Şu kadar bir de
kocaman bir suyunuz var işte çaydanlık
da bu olsun tamamen suyla dolu bu 10
gram olsun Bu 500 gram olsun 50 kat daha
fazla sahip bunları aynı ocakla yani
aynı enerji miktarıyla ısıtmaya
çalışıyoruz ikisinin de sıcaklığını 20
selsiustan 21 celsius'a çıkartmaya
çalışıyoruz veya kaynatmaya da çalışıyor
olabilir Çok önemli değil 100 selsiyse
de çıkarmaya çalışıyor olabiliriz
hangisi önce Kaynar günlük hayat
deneyimlerinize uygun olarak cevap verin
Tabii ki küçük miktardaki daha çabuk
Kaynar İkisi de su olduğu için bir kere
bunların Öz ısıları aynı fakat öz ısısı
1 gram üzerinden yapılan tanım elinizde
10 gram varsa bu adama 10c'lik enerji
vermen gerekiyor elinde 500 gram varsa
bu adama 500c'lik bir enerji vermen
gerekiyor Ocaklar aynı çalışıyorlar yani
Birim zamanda verdikleri enerjiler aynı
Dolayısıyla şunu vermek daha uzun
sürecektir Bu da Isı sahası kavramıdır
Isı sahası maddenin kütlesi ile öz
ısısının çarpılması ile bulunur yani MC
ile bulunur büyük c harfi ile gösterilir
sembolü budur diyebiliriz Peki bu adam
ayırt edici bir özellik midir Hayır
ayırt edici bir özellik değildir sebep
Çünkü 10 gram suyla 500 gram suyun Isı
sahası aynı değil ayırt edici
özelliklerin sabit olması gerekir sabit
olsun ki hep ayırt etsin kimliğiniz gibi
Kimlikte yazan bilgileriniz adını
soyadınız doğum tarihiniz hep aynı sizi
ayırt ediyor diğer vatandaşlardan
kimliğiniz zaman içerisinde sürekli
değişseydi artık size ayırt edemezdi
madde miktarı yani kütle değişken olduğu
için Isı sahası ayırt edici bir özellik
değildir birimi kalori bölü selsiyus ya
da juli celcius yine birazdan
çıkartacağımız formülde bu birimleri
tekrar konuşacağız niye böyle
olduklarını konuşacağız kütle ve öz
ısısı büyük olan maddelerin yani büyük c
ile gösterdiğim Isı sahası fazla olan
maddelerin sıcaklığını değiştirmek için
maddeye daha fazlası verilmesi ya da
maddeden daha fazla ısı alınması gerekir
Öz ısısıyla çok benziyor fakat orada hep
1 gram sınırlandırmamız vardı burada
madde miktarı sınırlandırmamız yok öz
ısısı büyük olan zaten zor ısınıyordu
zor soğuyordu E bir de bunu işin
içerisine kütle girerse daha da çok zor
ısınır ya da daha da çok zor soğur ısı
sahasıyla öz ısısı arasındaki fark bu
Isı sahası Öz ısısıyla içeriyor hemce
bir deneyeceğiz Ama deneyden önce
çözelim bir dolusu su ve bir sürahi
dolusu suyla ilgili bazı sorular
verilmiş bu sorulara cevap vereceğiz
hangisini ısıtmak ve soğutmak daha
zordur İkisinde de su var mı var o zaman
bunların Öz ısıları küçük c'leri aynı mı
Aynı O zaman ikisini de ısıtmak soğutmak
aynı zorluktadır diyemeyiz İkisi de 1
gram olsaydı Evet ama bunların Kütleleri
aynı değil Burada ağzına kadar dolu bir
sürahiden bahsediyoruz burada bir
bardaktan bahsediyoruz bunun kütlesi bir
emse bunu kütlesi 50m Isı sahası kütle
çarpı öz ısı olduğuna göre soldakinin
sıcaklığını bir derece arttırmak için
ona 50m çarpı c'lik enerji vermem
gerekiyor sağdakinin sıcaklığını bir
derece arttırmak için hem çarpı c'lik
enerji vermem gerekiyor yani soldakine
50 kat daha fazla enerji Vermeliyim Bu
da daha fazla vakit demek daha zor bir
işlem demek o yüzden sürahi ısıtmak ve
soğutmak daha zordur Tabii içindeki
sudan bahsediyorum suların
sıcaklıklarını bir selsiyus arttırmak
için verilmesi gereken enerji miktarı
suların ilk sıcaklıklarına bağlı mıdır
soruda şöyle bir şey dedim mi Ben
gençler bunların ikisi de 10 celsius'da
aynı sıcak böyle bir kısıtlamam var mı
Yok aynı olmak zorunda değiller ki bu 50
olsaydı da aynı şeyi konuşurduk Çünkü
Tanım ne bir selsius değiştirmek Yani bu
50 ise bunu 50'den 51'e çıkartacağız
bunu da ondan 11'e çıkartacağız ilk
sıcaklığın bir önemi yok Önemli olan
değişim miktarı ilk sıcaklıklara Bu
yüzden bağlı değil tabii öz ısı aslında
gerçekte sıcaklıkla da değişebilen bir
şey fakat biz lise müfredatı içerisinde
Öz ısıyı sabit kabul ediyoruz sürahinin
içerisinde su yerine alkol olsaydı
bardaktaki suya göre daha mı zor
ısınırdı güzel şimdi sürahideki suyu
boşaltıyoruz onun yerine alkol koyuyoruz
Burada alkol var parantez içinde bilgi
var diyor ki suyun öz ısısı bir kalori
böyle gram selcius alkolün öz ısısı 0.58
kalori bölü gram selfius ikisinde
sıcaklığını bir selsiyus değiştireceğim
Yani ısıtmaya çalışıyorum diyelim ki Bir
maddenin sıcaklığını 1 saat sürüyor
arttırmak istiyorsam ona vermem gereken
enerji miktarı ısısı az hem çarpıcı
kütle büyükse fazla enerji vermem lazım
alkolün kütlesi büyük fazla enerji
vermem lazım ama alkolün de öz ısısı
küçük suya göre yani şurası küçük
Dolayısıyla bir sürahi dolusu alkolü
ısıtmak daha zor denemez Çünkü ben
buradaki büyüklük küçüklük ilişkisini
bilmiyorum E hocam buna 50 ml dediniz
buna birem dediniz burada 0.50 var
Yaklaşık yani 0.5 C desem şuna 25mc
vermem gerekir Bu zaten Birce buna MC
vermem gerekir bakın yine alkole daha
fazla enerji vermem gerekiyor İyi de bu
sayıları Ben böyle verdiğim için Burası
Elm değil de bir buçuk mm olsaydı yani
yine sudan daha büyük bir değer olsaydı
0.5 ile çarptığında
0.75 MC olurdu bak su daha fazla kaldı
alkol daha az çıktı kütleleri bana
vermediği için ben o elli yemleri falan
kafamdan uydurduğum için herhangi bir
işlem yapamam sadece diyebilirim ki
kütle artarsa Isı sahası artar öz ısı
azalırsa ısı alsa azalır bunların
miktarlarını bilmiyorum Dolayısıyla c
şıkkı ile ilgili kesin bir yorum
yapılamaz bir sürahi dolusu alkol daha
kolay ısıtılabilir bir bardak suya göre
Isı sahası ile ilgili güzel bir
deneyimiz var Burada 4 tane balon var
birinci balon içerisinde sadece hava var
ikinci balonumuz sadece suya daldırılıp
çıkartılmış içinde hala hava var 3
balonumuzun içerisinde su var 20
mililitrelik Su 4 balonumuzda ise su var
ama 40 mililitrelik su Yani soldakinde
daha az su var sağdakinde daha çok su
var diyebiliriz su zaten öz ısısı havaya
göre çok daha büyük bir madde
Dolayısıyla havaya göre ısıtması daha
zor ve bir de bunu Isı sahası olarak
düşünüp yanına kütle koyduğumda kütlesi
büyüdükçe de işler iyice zorlaşıyor
Çünkü Isı sahası büyük olan maddeleri
ısıtmak daha zordur sıcaklığını
değiştirmek daha zordur Ben bunların
altına 4 tane Özdeş mum koydum Yani
bunlar Birim zamanda aynı ısı enerjisini
alıyorlar önce hangisi patlar deney bu
Bakalım önce hangisi patlıyor 22
saniyede birinci balon patladı 24'te
ikinci patladı hemen peşinden üçüncü
balonumuz şu an süre akıyor hala
patlamadı birazdan kaç dakika geçtiğini
göreceğiz patladığında
1.44'te patladı dördüncü balonumuz ise
patlamıyor ısrarla Ben ileri sarayım
sizi yormayayım 4 balon
7.57'de patlıyor bu arkadaş 22 saniyede
patlarken Bu 24 de patladı bu 1 dakika
22 saniyede patlarken bu 7 Bilmem kaçta
patladı Çünkü balonun patlaması için o
plastiğin belli bir sıcaklık değerine
ulaşması lazım aynı suyun kaynama
noktasına ulaşması gibi düşünebilirsiniz
ancak o sıcaklığa ulaştığında tanecikler
artık kafayı yiyorlar içeride kinetik
Enerjileri devasa artıyor bütünlük
bozuluyor patlıyor balon bu 4 balon
arasında ne fark var
Isı sahası farkı var Yani bunların hem
kütleleri farklı hem de Öz ısıları
farklı bir kere dördünde de aynı plastik
var plastik olarak dörde de Özdeş balon
bunların içerisinde hava var bunların
içerisinde su var suyun öz ısısı havanın
Öz ısısından büyük Dolayısıyla buna C
dersem Isı sahası olan c'den
bahsediyorum Buna da C derim sallıyorum
buna 10c'dir buna 15 c'dir Bunlar Niye
daha küçük Çünkü İçinde su yok öz ısısı
küçük olduğu için sağa küçük Bunların
içinde su var peki bu niye en büyük
Çünkü burada çok su var kütle artarsa da
ısı asa artar ve ısı sağsa artarsa o
maddenin sıcaklığını zor değiştirirsiniz
daha fazla enerji ister O sıcaklığa
ulaşmak 7 dakika sürer ama ısı sağınız
küçükse o sıcaklığa ulaşmak 22 saniye
sürer benzer bir deney daha var bakın
bir ateş kaynağımız var plastiği çok
kolay bir şekilde eritiyor Deliyor fakat
içerisinde su olan kısmını tuttuğu zaman
orayı delemiyor oradan suyu fışkırması
lazım değil mi fışkırmıyor Çünkü bu
kısmın Isı sahası çok büyük Isı sahası
büyük olduğu için o erime sıcaklığına
plastiğin o delinmesi için gereken
sıcaklığa bir türlü ulaştıramıyor Çok
fazla süre enerjiye maruz bırakması
lazım ki orası delinebilsin gördüğünüz
gibi bu video sınırları içerisinde biz
bu durumu göremiyoruz nasıl sahası
büyükse sıcaklığı Değiştirmek zor geldik
Bütün bu konuştuklarımızı toparlayan
formülle kesinlikle bilinmesi gereken
q = MC Delta t'ye buna kulak
aşinalığınız olabilir Daha önce duymuş
olabilirsiniz Aslında tüm
konuştuklarımızın özetidir bu ifade Bir
maddenin sıcaklığını değiştirmek için
ona Isı enerjisi vermelisiniz
q burada Isı enerjisi biliyorsunuz daha
önce maddeye ne kadar çok ısı enerjisi
verirsen sıcaklığını o kadar fazla
arttırırız o kadar fazla değiştiririz
yani Bir maddeyi 5 dakika ısıttığındaki
sıcaklık değişimi ile 20 dakika
ısıttığındaki sıcaklık değişimi aynı
değil maddenin mc'si yani büyük c'si Isı
sahası ne kadar büyükse onun sıcaklığını
değiştiremezsiniz o kadar zor olur bu iş
payda büyürse sonuç küçülür basit
matematik Sabahtan beri konuştuğumuz şey
balon deneyinde hepsi aynı sıcaklıktaydı
diyelim ki hepsi 10 celsi ustaydı
balonun patlaması için 50 celsius'a
gelmesi gerekiyordu sallıyorum 4 Balonda
da buradaki sıcaklık değişimi artık 40
sel suyu olmalıydı hepsinde bu Delta te
ortaktı Bu yüzden ıssız sahası büyüdükçe
vermem gereken q miktarı da Art burada
vermem gereken q'yu zamanla
eşleştirebilirsiniz zihninizde Çünkü bu
minimum hep aynı senarysini veriyor bir
saniyede zaman ilerledikçe daha çok
enerji vermiş oluyor o yüzden
Isı sahası büyük olan içinde hem su var
hem de çok miktarda su var olan balon
büyük amcaya sahip olduğu için büyük
q'ya ihtiyaç duyduğu yani büyük zamana
ihtiyaç duydu 7 dakikada patladı bütün
konuştuklarımızın özeti bu burada İçler
dışlar çarpımı yaparsak q = MC Delta T
dediğimiz kesinlikle bilmeniz gereken
ifadeyi bulmuş oluruz şimdi dersin
başında konuştuğumuz o birimleri
çıkartalım Öz ısının birimi nedir Ben bu
formülde C'yi yalnız bırakıyorum
q/m Delta t'dir bu q'nun birimini ısı
sıcaklıkta kalori olarak düşünürsem bu
arkadaşı gram bu arkadaşı celsius olarak
düşünürsem Öz ısının birimi kalori bölü
gram çarpı celsius olarak dersin başında
konuştuğumuz gibi düşünülür veya ben bu
formülü Şuradaki MC Isı sahası olduğu
için q = büyük C çarpı Delta T olarak da
yazabilirim bu ısı sahasını yalnız
bırakırsam q / Delta T olur q'nun
birimini kalori Delta T de celsius
olarak alırsam ısı sahasının birimi
kalori bölü selsiyus olarak kolaylıkla
çıkartılabilir R ve 2r yarıçaplı
demirden yapılmış küreler şekildeki
gibidir R yarıçaplı kürenin sıcaklığının
10 selsiyus artması için küreye
verilmesi gereken Isı enerjisi ile iki
ayarı çaplı kürenin 10 selsiyesi
soğuması için kürenin vermesi gereken
Isı enerjisi miktarlarını oranlayın
şimdi bunların ikisinin de Delta t'si 10
celcius ister artsın ister azalsın
değişimdir Çünkü Delta sıcaklıktaki
değiş bizim ifademiz q = MC Delta T
bunların alacağı Isı enerjisi ya da
vereceği ısı enerjisini soruyor Yani
aslında bu q'yu soruyor bana İkisinde de
Delta tlera 10 celcius ortak O zaman
benim burada ilgileneceğim şey nedir
mc'dir kütle çarpı Öz ısıdır yani ısı
sağdır İkisi de demir değil mi Bu
arkadaşların Evet o zaman bunların Öz
ısıları da aynı Çünkü öz ısı maddelerin
cinsine bağlı ayırt edici bir özelliktir
iki kürenin de bir gramını alsak
sıcaklıklarını 10 derece arttırmak için
aynı enerjiyi veririz ama bunlar birer
gram değil kütleleri farklı o zaman
düşünmem gereken şey Öz ısının kütleli
versiyonu yani ısı saz yani emce ortak
olduğu için tek bakmam gereken şey
kütledir hocam bunların kütlelerini
vermemiş ki yarıçaplarını vermiş ben
nereden bileyim kütlelerini o zaman
önceki bir konumuza başvuracağız yani
Özkütle de eşittir en bölü ve ben
bunların yarı çaplardan hacmini
hesaplarsam kütlelerini de hesaplamış
olurum Çünkü ikisi de demir olduğu için
bunların özküt küre hacmi 4/3 p x r³ ile
bulunur R yarıçaplı kürenin hacmi budur
Sağdaki 4/3 p x 2 r'nin küpüdür Bu da
4/3 p x 8 rakip demektir Ben bu ifadeye
V hacim dersem bu ifadeye 8 ve hacim
demeliyim bu arkadaş sabitken Hacim ne
kadar büyükse kütlenin o kadar büyük
olması lazım yani sen V hacimli madde en
kütlelidir dersen 8 ve hacimli maddenin
8M kütlesi olması gerekir ders bunun
kütlesi 1 M ise bununki 8m'dir soru
bitti soldaki küre için yazıyorum
q eşittir M çarpı C çarpı 10 Sağdaki
küre için yazıyorum 8M çarpı C çarpı 10
o zaman buradaki Isı enerjisi 8q
olmalıdır birinci kürenin sıcaklığını
arttırıyoruz Demek ki bizim buna şu
kadar enerji vermemiz gerekiyor ikinci
madde soğuyor o zaman bunun dışarıya ısı
enerjisi vermesi lazım Ne kadar vermesi
lazım
8q kadar Isı enerjisi vermesi lazım
sorumuzun cevabı oranlama olduğu için
1/8'dir xyz cisimlerinin kütle verilen
ısı sıcaklık değişimi değerleri tabloda
verilmiş Buna göre yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur denilmiş Şimdi ben ne
görüyorum x maddesi var Buna q kadar
enerji verdik M kütleli bir madde
sıcaklığı T kadar değişmiş benim genel
ifadem q=mc Delta t o zaman ben bu x
maddesinin Öz ısısına C dedim şimdi y'yi
yazıyorum bu arkadaşa q enerji verilmiş
kütlesi 2m sıcaklık değişimi de 2t aynı
ifadeyi bulmak için x'e C dediğim
ifadeyi bulmak için buraya c/4 Yazmam
gerekir ki şu 2 çarpı 2 4 o 4'le de
aşağıdaki dört birbirini götürsün ve
aynı genel ifadeyi bulalım Z için
yazarsam 4 q enerji veriyoruz hem
kütleli bu arkadaş ama sıcaklığını T
kadar değiştirebiliyoruz yine şu genel
ifadeyi bulmak için buraya 4C Yazmam
gerekir ki şu 4 de şu 4 götürsün yine bu
arkadaşı elde ederim
demiş olduk matematik üzerinden düşünmüş
gibi oldum şimdi de fizik üzerinden
düşünelim bakın x de M küt
grafik sorusu biraz daha farklı bir soru
tipi klm cisimlerine ait sıcaklık
verilen ısı grafiği şekildeki gibidir
Buna göre bu cisimlerin ısı sığalarını
kıyaslayınız güzel yine genel ifademi
yazıyorum q = MC Delta T sıcaklık
ısı grafiği grafik okumayı kesinlikle
öğrenmelisiniz hareket konusundan beri
bunu yapıyoruz çeşitli konularda gördük
grafinya eğimine Bakarız ya alanına
Bakarız ya da grafiğin kendisini
inceleriz bana sorulan şey
Isı sahası yani Şuradaki MC Ben bu mc'yi
yalnız bıraksam
q/ Delta T olur yani maddeye verdiğin
ısı enerjisini o maddenin sıcaklık
değişimine bölersen Elde ettiğin ısı
sığasını buluyorsun Peki bunları ters
çevirsen bir böyle MC yapsam yani 1/0 o
zaman sağ tarafı da ters çevirmeliyim ne
olur Delta T bölü olur peki bu grafikte
düşe Eksen olan sıcaklığı yatay Eksen
olan ısıya bölersem grafiğin nesini
Bulurum eğimini bulurum bölme işlemi
eğim verir Delta t'yi q'ya bölmek Yani
bu grafiğin iyi mi Bana bir böyle mc'yi
veriyor bir bölü büyük C'yi veriyor yani
1/ sahasını veriyor eğim ne kadar
büyükse bu ifade o kadar büyüktür bu
ifadenin büyük olması için de payda
kısmının küçük olması gerekir
Dolayısıyla cümleyi tam kuralım sıcaklık
ısı grafiğinde eğim ne kadar büyükse
ısı sığası o kadar küçüktür en dik olan
hangisi leğenin
Isı sahası en küçüktür k ile M aynı
eğime sahip paralel Bunlar k ile m'nin
ısı sahalara eşittir ve l'ye göre daha
düz oldukları için eğimleri küçük olduğu
için 1/c'leri küçük 1/c sonucunun küçük
olması için payda kısmındaki bu ısı
sahasının büyük olması gerekir O yüzden
Kaan'ın ve m'nin Isı sahası l'den
büyüktür sorunun cevabı bu yine biraz
matematik üzerinden düşündük fizikçe
düşünelim Bakın grafiğin şu kısmında 3
kiloluk enerji verilmiş 3 maddede Kaya
da lydi 3q'luk enerji verilmiş bu
enerjiye karşılık K nasıl tepki vermiş
sıcaklığını 2 TL'den 3D'ye çıkartmış
Yani bunun sıcaklığı T kadar artmış
l'ninki 0'dan 3D'ye çıkmış Yani bunun
sıcaklığı artı 3D artmış m'ninki 0'dan
t'ye çıkmış artı t'lik bir sıcaklık
değişimi var q=mc deltate bunların üçüne
de aynı enerjiyi veriyoruz 3q bu sabit
eşitliğin sol tarafı sabitse sağ
tarafında sabit kalması lazım Çünkü bu
bir eşitlik O zaman senin ıssız sığan
büyükse sıcaklığın daha az değişir
sıcaklığın değişemez
ısı soğan küçükse sıcaklığın çok değişir
l'nin sıcaklığı çok değişmiş Çünkü l'nin
Isı sahası küçük k ile m'nin sıcaklığı
az değişmiş Çünkü bu arkadaşların ısısı
sahası büyük ve eşit değişiklikleri için
ısı Sahaları kendi içlerinde eşit sadece
formül üzerinden düşünmeyin Bu fiziksel
yorumları da yapın bunları da hayal et
Bu video bu kadar takıldıktan azalta
yazın Kendinize iyi bakın görüşürüz
[Müzik]